it wasn't just lebron james rushing to
judgment making dumb comments in order
to vilify the police
top obama advisor valerie jarrett
blasting law enforcement for quote
intervening
in a simple knife fight okay
uh tell me what's wrong with that
statement she didn't seem to care that a
young african-american
girl unarmed was about to be stabbed to
death her only problem is that what a
white
police officer intervened and saved that
innocent girl's life
and then there was this tweet from a
prominent blm activist teenagers
they have been fighting including fights
involving knives for eons
we don't need police to address these
situations by showing up
to the scene and using a weapon against
one of the teenagers
this was actually by definition not a
knife fight
this was an attack an unarmed girl was
about to be stabbed she was
unarmed no fight there but that didn't
stop the
ladies of the hard-hitting abc news show
the view
from blasting the actions of the police
officer
and also saying some in my opinion
pretty dumb things
i've looked at the tape and i still
can't figure it out um
shoot the gun in the air there's a
warning tase
a person shoot them in the leg shoot
them in the behind
you know stop them somehow we shouldn't
live in a country quite frankly
where it's acceptable for the police to
shoot a 16 year old four times in the
chest
over a fight it goes from zero to
execution very very quickly
when there is a black or brown person
involved it's really um
it's pretty unbelievable by the way
joyless behar
a warning shot in the air or in
the girl's backside really joy
the unarmed girl was going to be
stabbed in the next second if he shot
the gun in the air it would have been
too
late and she could have been killed
stabbed in the chest or the neck
like the 13 year old in ohio stabbed to
death
on monday now even worse one reporter
asking the police chief
well was he why did the officer shoot uh
mikaya bryant
in the leg uh one it probably wouldn't
have stopped that attack but
i'll let him answer a lot of people have
said
couldn't he have just shot her in the
leg so she dropped could he have shot
her in the arm something like that
right you know one of the uh the
difficult things with that
is um when you're trying we we don't
train to shoot the leg
because that's a small target we train
to shoot center mass what is available
to stop that threat
there was a threat going on a deadly
force threat that was going on so the
officer is trained to
shoot center mass the largest part part
of a body
that is available to them when you try
to start shooting legs or arms
rounds miss and then they continue on
and there are people behind that
that could be in danger that are not
committing anything
when you use deadly force to prevent a
murder you aim for center mass
that's how every police officer is
trained always
and unless you want to miss uh risk
missing and hitting bystanders or other
innocent people
remember they were in very close
proximity the
the girl that was about to be stabbed
and the girl doing the stabbing
incredible professionalism and
marksmanship
on the part of the police officer to
save a human life
these aren't just idiotic words from the
mob and the media and celebrities and
democrats
sadly they're backed up by idiotic
actions
in city after city unusually by liberal
democrats for decades
police budgets have been slashed new
policies
prevent police from making arrests if
you can believe it
zero bail like they have in new york are
putting criminals
immediately right back out on the street
hours after committing the first crime
and if signed into law this george floyd
justice and policing act
yeah that will end all policing forever
it would allow
americans to sue individual police
officers
over any perceived on-duty infraction
and get this officers they would have to
hire their own lawyers
and pay massive out-of-pocket legal
bills
now you don't have to have a degree from
harvard or
mit to figure out that if this
legislation passes
no one will ever not only want to be a
police officer be
able to be a police officer because they
can't afford to be a police officer
under those conditions because what's
going to happen everybody that is
arrested
they're going to sue the officer every
time then there will be nobody arrested
and well they'll succeed in deep funding
and dismantling the police
and by the way in every city where
police officers have been defunded
or have been ordered to pull back guess
what shouldn't shock you
murders are way up now couple that with
the ongoing stream of hate and rage
against law enforcement
the danger that they already face has
now gotten more dangerous every day
there'll be police shortages the likes
of which this country has never
seen lawlessness like we've never seen
one study quote blm protested there's a
direct correlation with the 10
increase of murder nationwide murders up
nearly 40 percent
this year alone and the years that they
analyzed in this study there was
somewhere between a thousand and six
thousand more homicides than there would
have been
if those protests never occurred some
might call them riots in some cases
harvard economists backed this up in
baltimore chicago cincinnati
ferguson missouri riverside california
they found there were almost 900 more
homicides
34 000 more felonies as cops pulled back
but the rage keeps coming this week in
oklahoma
rioters storm the capitol building to
protest the bill
that makes it illegal to dox police
officers
now congresswoman ocasio-cortez our
so-called squad
they've called for policing to be
abolished despite
guess what they spend thousands of
dollars on private security
aoc spent between three thousand five
thousand dollars a month
then there's maxine waters this week
calling for violent confrontations on
the streets if they don't get
if she didn't get the verdict that she
wanted and she expected
now congressman steve scalise has
responded to her
remember he was gunned down on that
baseball field back in 2017
he barely survived that attack and it
was a targeted attack against
republicans
he responded saying let's be clear
maxine waters knew her rhetoric would
incite violence in minneapolis
she doesn't care she just requests
police escorts for herself
as we have been reporting i was shot
because of this kind of dangerous
rhetoric
where's the outrage from democrats and
the media mob they need to condemn this
instead of condemning waters rhetoric
they defended her they killed the
resolution in the house
criticizing her rightly for the call to
violence
if the verdict didn't come back the way
she thought it should come back
democrats really though only seem to
care about acts of violence
if it can be used for political gain
that's why you don't hear a peep from
the left
about the scourge of gang violence in
many of america's cities
murders are going up in almost every
major city in the
in the entire country democrats just
pretend like it's not happening
just like they deny riots are happening
uh but they
love to call out insurrection when that
insurrectionist talk
how many people tonight how many have
heard the name of
jocelyn adams how many people are
chanting her name how many marches are
conducted in her honor
remember she was a seven-year-old little
girl that was shot dead
at a mcdonald's drive-through in chicago
what about the seven-year-old who was
shot and killed this week in north
carolina
he had a name also his name was zacharin
graylin harris look at your screen why
haven't you heard the names of any of
these
innocent young boys and girls murdered
because of gang violence in american
cities
why don't you hear the names of these
police officers
now over a hundred killed in the line of
duty so far this year 103 to be
exact let me tell you why because it
doesn't fit their political narrative
their agenda so there are no protests in
their honor
no calls for action there's not
widespread acknowledgement of their
names or demands for justice
pretty much we hear nothing nothing at
all
103 dead officers might surprise some
people but they have families too
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else